We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. I
don't know if this voicemail is for real or
not, but let's take a listen to it.
It's about Bernie's three houses.
Hi David.
It's calling from [inaudible].
Sorry, it's calling from Washington state.
I had a question about Bernie Sanders.
Uh, my dad who listens to conservative radio
all the time.
He claims that Bernie raised a lot of money
outside of, of, uh, selling his book and he's
got like three houses or something.
Okay.
Possibly make a big deal on that and clear
that out.
So I don't know that I believe, you know,
three houses or something.
I don't know that I believe this is a sincere
voicemail, but let's, let's see if we can
desegregate this.
Bernie did not raise money by selling a book.
Bernie wrote a book and that's a commercial
endeavor and he made money from selling it
several, many hundreds of thousands of dollars
as would be expected from a politician of
his stature and notoriety in society.
Bernie raised money for his campaign from
individuals and uh, Bernie does have three
houses.
And what matters is that Bernie wants health
care for everybody.
Bernie wants higher taxes on the very rich
to pay for things that would benefit all of
society, so on and so forth.
Bernie's net worth of, I believe it was one
point $1 million is not at all outrageous
for a guy who's nearly 80 years old and has
made six figures for quite some time now as
an elected official at the top level in the
United States.
And my instinct is that this is concerned
fake concern trolling.
Um, but if it's a serious question, no, you
don't have to be worried about that.
Go by the policies and then you will very
quickly see when you compare Bernie Sanders
to Donald Trump or to Joe Biden whose policies
would be best for the greatest number of people.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Donald Trump, uh, ramping
up outreach to black voters after the state
of the union push.
We will talk about some interesting new studies
about the interplay between an individual's
brain chemistry and whether or not antidepressants
will work.
And then lastly, it turns out that millennials
are better
at saving money in the philosophical sense,
but he'll have less money.
We'll talk about why that is.
All of those stories and more on today's [inaudible].
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].